donc frédéric tu ne le crois pas en dieu
je pense que dieu est peut-être mais en
tout cas certainement sous aucune des
formes que l'on nous a enseigné et et
moi j'ai sommes finalement samou c'est
affreux à dire mais ça m'intéresse pas
est ce que ton fils mathieu est baptisée
wii il est baptisé parce que
j'attache beaucoup d'importance à vous
fait qu'un enfant
[Musique]
soit comme les autres et ça fait partie
de notre culture de notre de notre vie
et après il est libre de faire ce qu'il
veut donc il ya des gens qui tiennent le
raisonnement inverse
moi j'ai préféré celui-là la cage
maintenant il a 20 ans 21
on n'a jamais su si c'était ton ombre et
fils ou ton fils adoptif alors c'est
tout à fait mon vrai fils c'était une
c'est à dire que c'est
il a vécu avec moi d'une manière un peu
compliqué à cause du désordre de la
jeunesse qui était ma jeunesse
en l'occurrence mais c'est mon vrai fils
et puis même si les témoins fils adoptif
il serait aussi mon vrai fils toute
façon je trouve terrible cette
différence la seule chose qui compte
c'est la manière dont les gens
s'occupent des autres mais en tout cas
c'est mon vrai fils est ce que tu vois
toujours sa mère
[Musique]
non parce que
la drogue à djebbour john kyl élevé je
les ai élevés mais pas très bien c'est à
dire que je ne m'en suis pas assez bien
occupé que j'étais sans doute un peu
tyrannique avec lui je lui fais ch et de
respirer quoi et
et voilà il faudrait lui demander à lui
si tu devais mourir là quelle serait la
seule chose que tu voudrais lui dire à
ce moment là je t'aime et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous y mettez un pouce bleus